xcom is a fantastic turn-based strategy
series and the standalone spin-off
chimera squad makes some big changes to
tactics to help you avoid the kind of
mistakes that will end your first play
through early
we're going to get you caught up on
x-com chimera squad's new mechanics
number one breach breaching is one of
chimaera squad's most enjoyable
additions to xcom
in previous games you always had the
option to rip open a wall and make your
own fun but now it's mandatory
each mission has a number of set
encounters typically one to three and
each encounter starts with a breach
this seems to be an interesting solution
to cutting down on running in overwatch
between
fights the absolute most important thing
to understand about breaching is that
the order you stack up on the door
determines both the order the agents
enter the room and also where they take
cover afterwards you can change the
breach order with these small arrows up
top
they're kind of easy to miss you cannot
however control precisely where agents
take cover so
plan carefully that being said don't be
afraid to restart if things aren't
looking too good
the order of your agent's breach is also
critical because they have breach
specific abilities
for example who you levitate who you
blind and who you spray acid on can make
a big difference
agents can also have breaching gear like
flashbangs and smoke
in order to use it you'll need to stack
them up on the door in a way that makes
sense
for example the door kicker can't also
throw a grenade breaching gear can be
found in this little area
also easy to miss some great tips for
breaching are
don't under commit to a breach point
since you don't know what's behind the
door
you don't want an agent in a room alone
there are usually multiple breach points
with different bonuses and penalties to
consider
which agent you assign matters so for
example make sure to send a tanky
character through a door
that roots them in place for a turn know
what the labels mean over enemies
these are aggressive alert and surprised
aggressive enemies will fire back in the
breaching phase and need to be dealt
with first then you can probably focus
on enemies you know will be a problem
down the line
if the room doesn't have aggressive
enemies you can avoid wasting defensive
breaching actions
that pull aggro at the expense of
shooting pay attention to how many
encounters you're about to do on a
mission
and conserve your resources for later
rooms if possible some abilities can
only be used once a mission
if there's only one encounter then
you're good light them up
finally like previous games you can
still make your own holes after breach
phase by tearing through walls with
explosives
and it's still a hell of a lot of fun
number two turn order there's a new
order listed on the right side of the
screen that mixes up good guy and bad
guy turns
so consider making your decisions not
based on who's the closest
or who has the most dangerous weapon but
on who's going next
in other words the person with the gun
next to you can be less dangerous than
the person at the back of the room who's
about to fire
you can also reference the turn order
which is listed over each enemy's head
each agent technically gets two actions
but certain equipment and gear doesn't
count against it just make sure to do
everything you want before firing
because that action almost always ends
the turn until you buy certain mods
later
early in the game it's good to just be
aggressive and go after the next enemy
in line but later on you should learn to
manipulate the turn order in your favor
for example there's a team-up mechanic
that lets you bring up one agent in the
order once permission
there are also team abilities that allow
you to swap places with fellow agents or
delay an opponent's action
some agents can also constrict enemies
and negate their turn
some can give away turns or lock down
enemies with psionic abilities
if you're in a good spot you can also
use preparation a type of hunker down
mechanic that increases your defensive
rating
gets rid of burning and also gives you
another turn in fairly short order
before the end of the round
when you get the hang of turn order you
can do some really fun things like
teleport an enemy to your team and give
them a serious beatdown
speaking of beatdowns number three make
arrests
in chimera squad you are a paramilitary
police force which means
killing isn't the only or best option
you can and should make plenty of
arrests because they net you valuable
intel that you can then use to cut down
on
unrest unrest is an ever-present thing
you need to manage and failing to do so
can lose the game
more on that in a bit you can also trade
in intel on the black market for certain
items like weapon mods the arrest action
also appears to let you travel the full
distance of a dash and then attack
basically free run and gun
another caller a great technique to make
arrests
is to attempt to wound as many enemies
as possible during the breach phase and
then mop up the room with fisticuffs
there are specialized tools you can buy
later on such as tranquilizer rounds to
make arrests with less risk
arrests can also be a very satisfying
way to end an encounter
just don't try to knock out enemies in a
bad situation or
it might get you killed number four
death
if you're an xcom veteran you already
know that xcom can be punishing at
almost every difficulty
in chimera losing an agent fails the
game automatically and you'll have to
restart the encounter
agents die when they lose all of their
health and are not stabilized by a
teammate within a few turns
there are things you can do to lower
your chances of losing though such as
building android replacements
androids are squad replacements that
show up between breaches when an agent
is incapacitated they can be a bit
pricey but they come in clutch
if androids are damaged they can be
repaired back at base but if they're
destroyed
they are dead there is still technically
permadeath if you consider androids to
be alive
the other big thing you'll have to adapt
your mindset to is how gravely wounded
agents work differently
unlike previous xcom games they aren't
out of action for long periods of time
instead they develop negative traits in
the form of scars scars can cause
problems like greatly restrict movements
reduce your ability to land shots or
cause agents to panic
some of these scars can be a real
problem and it's in your interest to
either dedicate some time for those
agents at a training center to remove
the scars or put them on desk duty for a
while in the form of research projects
or spec ops missions which will net you
extra resources
number five unrest city 31 has an unrest
mechanic
similar to many previous xcom games if
you lose enough districts to unrest
you'll lose the city
and like other x-coms this can happen
long before you even know it so save
periodically
each district can have a field team
attached to it which you purchase with
intel
remember that bit about making arrests
earlier field teams have the ability to
reduce or even freeze the buildup of
unrest and can be upgraded to do even
more
do not neglect your field teams number
six
tweak early research priorities like
previous xcoms if you go into a mission
under equipped you can get yourself into
an unwinnable situation
unlike earlier xcom games you can
slightly tweak your priorities because
death and wounds work differently
agents with scars aren't fun but they
can be managed so here's a few
recommendations
you can probably put off armor research
a bit longer than you're comfortable
with to invest in android replacements
early armor research honestly doesn't
give you that much more protection
versus having a full squad member ready
to go as backup since androids do have
permadeath and are expensive to replace
take some time to boost their
survivability invest in breaching items
because they're really just a hell of a
lot of fun
entering a room protected by smoke or
with stunned enemies can be the key to
seizing early advantages
research and buy throwables that can
mess with the enemy team until you
develop agents to manipulate the turn
order
turn order is king i'm sure you have a
lot of thoughts about these changes to
the xcom formula and we want to hear
your best advice for how to play
let us know about your favorite tactics
in the comments below and check out our
other coverage of xcom chimera squad
thanks for watching
[Music]
you